This is Jocko podcast number
20 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink
around 8:00 PM on September 21st,
2007 the authority authority is
notified me that I should go for a mind
reeducation talk.
I found there were some unusual
things happening at this time.
The secret police who used to follow me
very closely kept the further distance.
I was walking down the street one day
and then when I turned a corner about six
or seven strangers started
walking towards me.
I suddenly felt a strong blowed the back
of my neck and fell face down on the
ground. Someone yanked my hair and a
black black hood was pulled over my head.
Immediately I was brought to
a vehicle and was put in it.
I couldn't see,
but it seemed that I had two
benches with a space in the middle.
I was putting the space in
the middle of the floor.
My right cheek was on the ground.
All of a sudden a boot was put on my face,
holding me down.
Many hands started searching all over me.
My belt was pulled off and used
to tie my hands behind my back.
At least four people put their feet on me,
holding me down.
About 40 minutes later I
was dragged out of the car.
My pants were falling down around my
knees and I was dragged into a room.
No one said anything at
all to me until that time.
The hood was pulled off my head.
At this time,
immediately men began
cursing and hitting me.
One of the men said,
your date of death has come today,
brothers. Let's give him a brutal
lesson today. Beat him to death.
Then for men with electric shock prods
began beating my head and all over my
body.
Nothing but noise and the beating of
my anxious breathing could be heard.
I was beaten so severely that my whole
body began uncontrollably shaking.
Don't pretend to do that.
I was shattered out by a guy whom
I later learned was named at Wang.
Then a very strong and tall man grabbed
my hair and pulled me up off the ground.
Then weighing began beating
me on the face terribly.
You are not worthy to wear clothes.
Pull off all of his clothes.
All of my clothes were pulled
off and I was totally naked,
weighing yelled again and someone
kicked me in the back of my legs and I
collapsed to the floor.
The big guy continued to pull my hair and
forced me to lift my head to see Wang.
At this time I could see that
there were five people in the room.
Four of the men were holding electric
prods and one was holding my belt.
You listen gow today your uncle's want
nothing but to make your life worse than
death.
While Wayne was saying this,
the electric shock prods were put on
my face and upper body, shocking me,
weighing then said, come on
guys, deliver the second course.
Then the electric shock Bhutan was
put all over me and my full body,
my heart, lungs, and muscles begin
jumping under my skin uncontrollably.
I was riding around on the ground in pain,
trying to crawl away,
weighing then shocked me and my genitals,
my begging them to stop,
only returned laughing and more
unbelievable torture weighing.
Then use the electric shock baton three
more times on my genitals while shouting
loudly.
After a few hours of this,
I had no energy to even beg,
let alone try to escape,
but my mind was still clear.
It seems that the torturers themselves
were also tired before the dawn came.
Three of them left the room.
We will come back later to give
them the next course. Wang said,
I asked,
how can you face the beating of Chinese
and use mafia tactics on Chinese
taxpayers?
You are an object to be beaten.
You know that in your heart better than
most taxpayers count for nothing in
China.
Don't talk about this term tax payers.
While he was saying this,
someone else also entered the room.
I recognize the voice to be Wang's.
Don't talk to him with your mouth.
Give him the real thing.
Your uncles have repaired 12 courses.
We only finished three last night.
Your chief uncle doesn't like to talk
and so following you will see that you
will have to eat your own
shit and drink your own piss.
Don't you talk about torture
by the Communist Party yet
because we will give you
a comprehensive lesson.
Now,
I am not afraid of you
if you continue to write.